wir gehen jetzt mal den ball vom fuß
das kann jetzt was dauer lederhosen
machen meine letzte rettung ja so viel
jemand eine vom rap bewaffnet haben
eigene cdu war in erster linie bin ich
dankbar für 23 tolle jahre dass man mein
wunschberuf und euch an wünsche ich für
die zeit die kommt bei aller härte die
auseinandersetzungen im wahlkampf geht
immer ordentlich miteinander rum danke
wolfgang bosbach werden natürlich jemand
gewesen der als minister auch glaube ich
viel zustimmung erfahren hätte bosbach
ist ein authentischer mensch war gestern
abend gesehen habe ich gesehen was sie
legen können variieren vornehme
zurückhaltung das recht ja die menschen
spüren
der sagt was er denkt kann jetzt schon
selber e mails lesen und beantworten er
steht nicht für parteipolitik sondern
steht für das wohl der menschen gerade
und deswegen darf man auch die leute nie
enttäuscht er hat immer ein gesicht der
cdu bleiben müssen demokrat er eckt an
er nervt ich glaub nicht zuletzt hat er
seine kanzlerin genervt ob die kanzlerin
ihrerseits so begeistert gewesen wäre
wenn sie einfach mit so einer nummer in
so einer sendung live eingeschaltet ist
wenn ich in der sendung sagen wenn sich
das nicht ändert dann gehe ich ja dann
weil ich das auch so mich wundert auch
überhaupt nicht dass der seinen
wahlkreis immer und immer wieder wurde
er hat eine sehr offene art seine
rheinische frohnatur kommt ihm da auch
zugute
das ist total lustig
es gibt alltägliche kleine reibereien
die kommen in den besten familien vor
und ja ein mann alleine hat es nicht
immer leicht
welcher mann hat denn ein problem damit
mit fünf frauen unter einem dach leben
darf das ist der pure luxus der traum
eines jeden mannes denkt auch seine das
sind die richtigen typen die
innenminister machen können da gibt es
ja keine diskussion
[Musik]